and they want to go after me because i  have they think a big mouth  i don't have a big mouth you know what i  have i have something about this woman's  facial expressions really really  bothering me also can  what is this  is is this appropriate right here what  the hell is this  now biden is bringing into the united  states tens of thousands of unvetted  unscreened afghan nationals that's  insane right  like does it matter whether these folks  are even asian  what the hell i can't believe i just  noticed that and i think there's a  couple of them and we're gonna resettle  them i guess with the child bride are  they doing that with the child bride  a lot of those people that rushed the  planes are not the people that worked  with us they're people that wanted to  get out you're going to see some bad  things happen over the coming years it's  a disgrace